everyone welcome to this next episode of
your daily equation and today I am going
to focus upon a deep issue one that we
could spend many episodes talking about
many hours talking about but I'm just
gonna really try to scratch the surface
here on the deep issue of the arrow of
time and its relationship to entropy and
the second law of thermodynamics so let
me just jump right in what's the puzzle
the puzzle is this there are a gazillion
processes in the world that we only ever
witnessed taking place in one temporal
order they unfold in one temporal
direction and we never see the reverse
of those processes right I mean we're
all familiar with the wind blows and the
the petals of a flower can be blown away
but if I showed you a film in which the
the flower reassembles itself you'd know
that I'm showing you a reverse run film
you never actually see that kind of
reconstruction taking place in the real
world around you we're all familiar for
another example someone can jump off the
side of a pool and do a whatever
somersault and land into a pool but if I
showed you a film in which someone jumps
out of the water the wall are all
coalesced to a nice flat surface and the
person lands on the pool surface you
know that I'm showing you a reverse run
film you've never seen that actual
process take place in the world around
you in the perhaps third and canonical
example we're all familiar it's happened
to me you're holding a nice glass of
wine maybe it's a Riedel glass you know
a real nice one it slips out of your
hand and it smashes on the floor awful
mess but you and I have never seen the
shards of glass on the floor all jump
off the floor come back together in just
the right way to reassemble a pristine
glass
filled with wine we never see such
processes and the puzzle or the issue
frame it down way the issue is to
explain this asymmetry why did we see
events unfold in one temporal order but
we never see those events in Reverse now
now one answer the quickest answer would
be well maybe the laws of physics allow
glasses to smash allow people to jump
into pools where the water becomes all
agitated they allow for wind to blow
petals of a flower whatever they're
called parts of a flower to blow off in
the wind but they simply don't allow the
reverse process to take place that would
be a great answer we only see the things
allowed by the laws of physics the laws
of physics don't allow those perverse
processes to take place you can film
them in the right order and play the
reverse but you can actually see them
take place in the real world in the
reverse order period end of story
that would be great problem is that
explanation fails as I'll show you in a
moment
any motion allowed by the laws of
physics the reverse motion is also
allowed by the laws if it's the reverse
process is allowed by the laws of
physics so we're back to square one and
trying to find an explanation and the
actual explanation that will actually
finally be led to is not to try to say
that the reverse processes can't happen
but rather to said that they can happen
it's just that they are extraordinarily
unlikely extraordinarily unlikely and
they're so unlikely that they
effectively never happen in the real
world that is the basic idea and trying
to make that a little bit more precise
will bring in the concept of entropy
second law of thermodynamics and at the
end though we'll find a little bit of a
twist in that to really finish this top
level argument we're not going to dig
into the nitty-gritty details which are
fascinating
rich but they will take us down a rabbit
hole the twist however that we will
encounter is that we will need to bring
in properties of the universe near the
Big Bang to actually make these ideas
complete or at least this approach to be
complete not everyone agrees that this
approach is the correct approach ok so
that's the the basic issue at hand and
let's just quickly jump in so the
subject that we're talking about is
entropy and the arrow of time the fact
that there seems to be a built-in
orientation to the order in which events
unfold that's what we mean by the arrow
of time that time has an orientation
associated with it with space does not
seem to have you can do anything in
space but time seems to have this
asymmetric quality where does it come
from so I really just want to quickly
spell out two things number one I just
want to convince you quickly that the
laws of physics really do allow reverse
run processes to take place so reverse
processes can happen and then the second
thing that we will take a look at once
we're convinced that there's an issue
right if the reverse process these can't
happen there's no issue once there is an
issue we will talk about entropy order
disorder and
[Music]
the second law of thermodynamics which
we will see talks about the overwhelming
tendency of order to degrade into
disorder from an orderly glass to
degrade into a shattered disorderly
glass that's where we're going all right
so let's begin with point number one and
I'll do this in a specific example but
easily generalizable I just want you get
a feel for how we argue that the laws of
physics
once they allow one trajectory one kind
of motion they necessarily allow the
reverse trajectory how do we do that so
I'm gonna do a specific example let's
imagine that we have a baseball you know
I like baseball
even I'll admit it I like the Yankees
don't turn off the video okay but anyway
there isn't any baseball this these days
in any event so imagine you have a
baseball and it's hit from home plate it
soars into say the bleachers in the
outfield let's say the trajectory is
called X of T and let's say we set it up
so that T equal to zero is when the ball
is a home plate T equals one when it
lands and the bleachers clearly if that
was in units of one second that would be
a monster shot I don't think anyone has
ever hit a ball in one second from home
plate to the bleachers but just that one
B whatever unit it needs to be so that I
can just keep the math looking simple
from T equals zero to T equal to one now
the question is what about the reverse
trajectory that would look like say
starting in the bleachers and heading
back toward home plate and that
trajectory let's call it X tilde of T in
terms of its functional form that could
be written as X of 1 minus T as you see
X tilde at time 0 would be X of 1 which
is this location here
is X of 1 and X tilde of one would be X
of 0 over here as that is X of 0 so that
is the reverse run trajectory and what
we want to make clear is that if X of T
satisfies the equations of motion so
does X tilde of T I'm doing this purely
classically I'll mention the
generalization in a moment now what are
the equations of motion well it's just
the force of gravity which is equal to
the mass of the ball times the
acceleration due to gravity is M times D
2 X d t squared that is the equation
satisfied by X of T and now we want to
see if that equation is satisfied by X
tilde of T and that's not hard to work
out because let's consider let me keep
the colors semi consistent so let's
consider D X tilde DT so that is the
same as d of X of 1 minus T DT and then
of course can be written a d of X of 1
minus T with respect to 1 minus T which
is now a dummy variable that I couldn't
replace with anything as I will in a
moment but let's write that D of 1 minus
T DT using the chain rule now this
fellow over here derivative of 1 minus T
respect to T the 1 derivative the one
part just gives you 0 so you get
derivative of negative T respect to T so
it's just minus 1 that's all that that
is so a factor of minus 1 coming in and
then this term over here as I said 1
minus T is now a dummy variable which
hopefully not confusing me I'll now call
T it's just a derivative of a function
of a very function of a particular
argument and it's called 1 minus T in my
equation I'm gonna now call it T just
for simplicity whoops
that's unfortunate phone ringing where
is that phone would you please excuse me
for half a second guys
hopefully this is not a cologne yet to
take oh someone picked it up in the main
house I should have gotten rid of this
phone before I started this but in any
event sorry but we're worried so here we
have this expression so we have minus DX
DT
that makes good sense because the
velocity of the ball in the purple
starting in the bleachers it's heading
out in this direction whereas the red
one as it was reaching the bleachers was
adding a misdirection clearly this
purple is the opposite of this red that
makes perfect sense but now let's take
the second derivative in order to
analyze the question of whether X tilde
T satisfies Newton's second law I don't
have to do anything at all because look
when I took the first derivative oh oh
it's so irritating all right I'm gonna
have to get rid of this phone I'm gonna
break it it's gonna drive me nuts okay
how much normally I put the phone out
the door after out to do it this time
but in any event okay so what do we have
here so we have this this minus sign
that comes from the first derivative if
I take a second derivative it'll just
bring in another minus sign minus sign
times minus sign is plus sign and
therefore let me just switch back over
to here so if I have D to X tilde DT
squared that will just be D to X DT the
minus signs will cancel each other and
you just have to choose the argument
correctly because I didn't replace that
1 minus T by T just to keep the
functional form simple but the point is
once you get here you're done because
that's the only thing that comes into
Newton's second law
so bottom line if this trajectory
satisfies the equations of motion then
so does the reverse one now look this is
for a single ball which I'm viewing as a
single particle traveling under just the
force of gravity and we've shown that
any motion the reverse motion satisfies
the equations of motion you can
completely generalize this to any number
of particles acted on any collection of
forces even quantum mechanically this is
true it gets a little bit more
technically involved
so in Schrodinger's equation not
Newton's second law if you want the wave
function to evolve in the reverse
temporal order you need to take a
complex conjugation and Schrodinger's
equation you got the I in there it goes
to mine
i square root of -1 and so you have to
take the compass conjugate of the wave
function to make it all work out bottom
line though you get exactly the same
answer any evolution of the wave
function forward in time the reverse run
film if you will of the wave function
going the reverse temper order will also
satisfy the equations motion so I've
done the simple case but it totally
generalizes so that is point 1 there
really is an issue as I said at the
outset anything that happens in one
order it can happen reverse
unfortunately we cannot simply argue
that the laws of physics prevent those
kinds of phenomena from happening and
that's why we don't see them that is not
how our universe works ok so we want to
go on then to the potential answer where
we don't try to rule out these reverse
run processes but rather we want to
argue that they're incredibly unlikely
now it's not intuitively it's not hard
to get to that conclusion in fact let me
show you the smashing wineglass how
would you get it to reassemble and then
in our show some years ago fabric of the
cosmos we did a sort of playful example
of it I'll show you here so here's that
wineglass again and it's in my hand and
I drop it smashes on the table you get
all the shards now if I want this to
reassemble what would I need to do let's
hold it hold still I would need to run
around changing the velocity of each and
every particle reversing it just like
the baseball going to bleachers in
Reverse it's coming out of the bleachers
I need to reverse the velocity of every
single particle making up the glass the
air in the room the wine whatever
everything involved I need to reverse
its velocity and then if I allow it to
evolve forward in time with those new
reverse velocities it all comes back
together into the pristine glass so it
can happen and that's how you do it but
look how incredibly difficult it is to
do it you need to run around and change
all of those motions in a completely
precise and exact way
in order for it to all stitch back
together so there you get a sense of how
incredibly difficult it would be for
that physical process to be set up to
unfold in the usual orientation of time
going forward shards of glass going
forward in time reassembling the glass
but now let's see how we find the
mathematical version that describes how
unlikely this is and that is what brings
in this idea of entropy and entropy is a
word that I think many people are
familiar with in everyday discourse you
can think of it as a measure that's not
perfect by any means and many people
balk at this description but it's it's
really not bad especially on a first
pass approaches we're doing in this
episode entropy is a measure of disorder
and roughly we want to quantify the idea
that the pristine glass is ordered
compared to the completely disordered
state of the shattered wineglass and how
how will we get a measure of that and
and the answer to that really comes from
this guy over here Ludwig Boltzmann and
you see on his tombstone there's an
equation s equals K log W and that
formula embodies Boltzmann's definition
of entropy and the way in which it can
be used to quantify disorder what is the
basic idea said in words first and then
I'll write down the equation the idea is
this if a system is very disordered then
there are many rearrangements of its
ingredients that leave it looking very
disordered you know the canonical
example that people use just as an
analogy you know if your desk is
completely disordered you got the paper
clips all over papers and random
arrangements coffee cups whatever total
miss and if I then come in you're not
even looking and I rearrange that
disordered mess you walk back in the
room you don't even notice that I
rearranged it it was a disordered mess
when you left the room it's a disordered
mess when you came back in the room so
there are many many rearrangements of a
disordered system that go completely
unnoticed that leave the system looking
pretty much the same if you have an
ordered desk where the paperclips are on
their appropriate spot the pages are all
in a nice neat stack the books are all
alphabetically ordered on the back of
your desk whatever almost any
rearrangement you will notice because
the paperclips won't won't be where
they're supposed to be the books won't
be in the precise alphabet or the pages
won't be in that nice neat stack so
there are very few rearrangements of the
constituents of an ordered desk that
leave it looking pretty much the same
and there are a huge number of
rearrangements of the ingredients making
up a disordered decks that leave it
looking the same so the way to quantify
order versus disorder is to count the
number of rearrangements of the
ingredients that leave a system looking
pretty much the same that is in essence
what Boltzmann said and that's really
what his formula is so in some sense
then s is a measure of the number of
rearrangements that leave the overall
properties of a system unchanged
and when Boltzmann writes down this
formula he writes in terms of the
logarithm that's what that log means on
his tombstone he uses logarithm it's
very important mathematical detail I
don't want to get bogged down in the
mathematical details here but basically
the W on his tombstone is counting the
number of rearrangements obviously not
for a disordered desk but for a system
made up of particles
so as an example if I consider the air
in this room there are many
rearrangements of the particles of air
in this room that are unnoticed I'm
rearranging them right now okay I'm
doing a lot of rearrangement feels the
same temperatures pretty much the same
I'm breathing the same air the
macroscopic properties of the air in
this room do not change under an
enormous number of rearrangements of the
air molecules in this room on the other
hand if I had a different circumstance
here what if the air was all clustered
in a tiny region over here I might be
gasping for breath put that to the side
but if all the air was right here
then I'm severely limited in the number
of rearrangements that make that
configuration look the same because if I
move those particles outside that little
cluster then I can notice it it's only
if I keep them tightly clustered and
therefore a limited number of
rearrangements will keep that
configuration of air molecules unchanged
so if the air is in a nice tiny orderly
package very low entropy if it's widely
dispersed and moving this way and that
in my room in this office here then it
has higher entropy it is more disordered
and the basic idea of the second law of
thermodynamics is that there is a
natural tendency for systems to evolve
from order toward disorder or in terms
of entropy now from low entropy to high
or higher entropy and the reason for
that is again quite straightforward for
low entropy there are very few
configurations available for a high
entropy by definition there are many
more configurations of the constituents
available and if the constituents are
randomly moving about thermally jiggling
this way and that then just by the law
of numbers it's much more likely that
they're going to find
themselves in a higher entropy
configuration since there's so many
configurations that fit that bill and
quite unlikely that they'll find
themselves on a low entropy
configuration because they're very few
of those so if I had the gas clustered
in a small little region here as the gas
randomly jiggles about it's going to
ultimately fill the room it will go from
the ordered low entropy to the high
entropy and that is the natural course
of events simply by the logic of numbers
in the logic of probabilities and I like
to give you a little more of a feel for
that using another analogy concrete
example that I find particularly useful
which is imagine you have a hundred
pennies and the match in those hundred
pennies are are on on my desk here and
they're all heads up now that is a very
orderly configuration right if you think
about the degree of freedom to simply
change a head to a tail or a tail to a
head there's only one configuration that
has all heads you can't change the
disposition of any coin and keep it all
heads if I then were to have the penny
subject to thermal jostling let's ask so
I can pick the table making the pennies
bounce around some of them will then
flip over from heads to tails and if I
keep on going some of the tails will go
back to heads but many more heads will
turn into tails so over time the
juggling pennies will go from the
ordered configuration of all heads to a
far more disordered configuration which
has more of a mixture of heads and tails
simply because there are many more such
configurations and I want to just make
them that quantitative for you and half
a second and do a little fun little
simulation on that so take those hundred
pennies as our system and if I ask
myself if I'm looking at a configuration
that has all heads
how many rearrangements of that
configuration maintain all heads and by
rearrangement I'm just talking about
changing heads to tails and tell us that
it's not rearranging them in terms of
their locations just whether it's heads
or tails and there's only one
arrangement or
rearrangement every single penny has to
have heads period end of story there are
no other possibilities that meet the
stipulation that you have all heads very
unlikely configuration say if you drop
the pennies for it to land in them
because of that but what if I had not
all heads but ninety-nine heads at one
tail
how many configurations have one tail
well now there are a bunch of
rearrangement let's say the first coin
is tail and the other 99 our heads you
can rearrange that make it the second
coin tail in the first is back two heads
that still has 99 heads or the fifth
coin is tails or the lone tail is the
seventeenth corner the loan tells the
99th coin you see there are hundred
possibilities there are a hundred States
if you will that meet the stipulation of
having 99 heads and so if your randomly
throwing coins on the table its 99 it's
a hundred times more likely that you get
99 heads then you will get a hundred
heads and therefore much more likely
that you'll have at least one tail but
you can keep on going
what if you have 98 heads well now think
about it the two tails could be coins
one and two or coins one and three or
coins two and three or four and five or
six and seventy-seven right they're all
in fact 100 choose two if you know a
little combinatorics for the number of
configurations have two tails 100 choose
to that's a hundred times 99 divided by
two so it's 50 times 99 I think that's
four thousand nine hundred and fifty and
so it's almost five thousand times more
likely that you'll have two tails than
no tails keep on going but if you have
97 heads you work that one out again
three tails get bitcoins one two and
three or coins one two and four coins
one two and five or points two five and
seven you know it just keeps on going
and how many are they believe there are
160 1700 possibilities in that
particular case which is an interesting
large factor by were to be more likely
to have the
number of heads compared to the number
that I started out with with there was
no heads
what about 96 heads I don't really know
that one off of the top of my head so
I'm gonna just estimate it I believe
it's about 4 million so I can't give you
the exact number there if you're
interested it's easy to work out there's
100 choose 4 and this keeps on going and
the point is I don't care about these
exact numbers that we have here I just
care about the trend that is being
Illustrated the trend is that if you
have evermore tails it's ever more
likely that if you randomly drop the
coins you'll have that number of tails
in fact this keeps on going until you
get to the upper 50 heads and 50 tails
when it's an equal split and that one
it's not it's trying to bring up I do
want to show you that number I can find
if it I guess I have it here so I'm
going up on the screen there it is I
don't know how to pronounce that number
so I won't try but it's a big number
it's a big number so if you think about
these numbers as the entropy of the
state which should be the log of it you
see that the number is 1 for all heads
and is this huge number for 50 heads and
50 tails which means if I had these
coins on my table and I bang them jostle
them around kick the table as I
described you would expect over time you
would approach 50 heads or 50 tails or
something very close to that because
there are so many ways to realize that
state and so few ways to realize the low
entropy state of all heads and I want to
show you this drive from order toward
disorder from say the configuration with
all heads to one that has a mixture of
50/50 I have a little simulation that a
guy at the world science about really
smart guy Danny Swift made for me asked
to me I want a little computer
simulation to show the folk
on your daily equation how the coins 100
pennies evolve over time and he quickly
came up with this which is really cool
let me see if I know how to make it work
there it is all right so it asks me how
many coins are there let me actually do
a thousand make it even more dramatic
not a hundred just because the numbers
are even more extreme then it says how
many heads are up I'm gonna start in a
completely ordered state of say I'm
gonna do all tails what difference does
it make
I'm start with all tails so no heads up
and then it says how many we'd like to
flip so this is saying I'm kicking the
table how hard he kicking the table on
average how many coins will flip over
and I'm gonna say roughly speaking 25
coins on each kick are gonna change
their disposition either from tail to
head or head to tail they're gonna be
randomly chosen by the simulation and
how many times you want to kick the
table well it's a computer after all so
I don't have to kick it literally so let
me just say I don't know 2000 times that
happens and then how many tosses per
frame that's when I'm plotting it out
how quickly the plot will go oh no let
me go 4 per frame I don't even know if
that's a good number or not and you know
that the graph is gonna come out here so
I'm going to quickly try to bring it
over once that starts to go there it is
there's my graph notice that I started
in the ordered state down here over time
we're going closer and closer to the
50-50 split which here would be 500
heads and 500 tails
we've now gone from order all the way up
more entropy more disorder more disorder
and once we hit the 50/50 split then we
pretty much stay in that range there be
some fluctuations when I kick the table
and I get a little more heads than tails
or I don't know what you know yeah a
little more heads into house little more
tails and heads over here but for the
most part once we reach that maximal
entropy state we pretty much just
meander there it's not that we can't go
back to an ordered state like all heads
are all tails it's just so fantastically
unlikely how unlikely there's only one
state that has all heads
whereas we have this huge number that I
showed you before that hundred I don't
know what is what is a hundred billion
billion or whatever it is and I'd have
to count or maybe one hundred billion
billion billion have to count the number
of digits but there are so many states
that have this roughly 50/50 split and
that's why we ran during around them
some heads go to tails some tails go to
heads but on average we're pretty much
staying in the 50/50 split in this case
500 heads and 500 tails for us to go
down to here would be an incredibly
unlikely move we'd have to have the
coins all just flip in the right way
that singular way to yield all heads or
all tails which is highly unlikely to
happen and this is a nice example to
illustrate the move from low entropy to
higher entropy from order to disorder
and how unlikely the reverse process is
so if you think about for instance this
ordered state as our wineglass very few
rearrangements of the molecules of the
wineglass will leave it intact compared
to the number of rearrangements of the
shards that leave the shards in a
disordered mess you start moving the
molecules of the wine glass around it
breaks it deforms it warps whatever it
doesn't look the same any longer but you
start moving around the molecules of the
shards of glass and the splattered wine
and it's like the messy desk pretty much
looks like a disordered mess before
pretty much looks like a disordered mess
after so there are so many ways for the
molecules of that glass to be disordered
that high entropy state so few ways for
the molecules to be ordered in that
beautiful Riedel glass that once you go
the progression from order to disorder
it is very unlikely for the reverse
process to happen and we saw how
difficult the reverse process is you
have to change the velocities of all the
shards in just the right way for them to
come back together for that to randomly
happen in the real world is incredibly
unlikely right and the
there aren't people running around
changing the velocities of molecules and
atoms and the real world is just thermal
motion banging things around and for the
random thermal motion to happen to be
just right to make all the molecules and
all the shards of glass to do what I
showed you in that film extraordinarily
extraordinarily unlikely so there's our
arrow if you will of time
that's natural progression from order
toward disorder from low entropy to I
entropy and let me just make well three
staples number one this is the second
law of thermodynamics the natural
tendency to go from order to disorder
and you see that it doesn't really
require I mean if you take this in a
statistical mechanics course this will
be laid out in more rigor and more
formalism will be developed but in the
end of the day it's nothing but logical
reasoning with numbers and you know it's
but there very few ways to be ordered
and a huge number of ways to be
disordered and things are randomly
sampling the possibilities and it's more
likely that they will find themselves in
disordered States compared to orderly
once nothing to it in some sense and
that's why Einstein I believe that's why
Einstein described these kinds of ideas
as the only ones that he was confident
would never be overthrown right he knew
that his general theory of relativity
and special relativity they had to be
just approximate descriptions of the
world he was realistic about that he
imagined that one day they might be and
would be superseded but when it came to
these kinds of ideas he didn't think
that they'd ever be superseded because
they don't rely upon anything but kind
of logic and numbers okay that's sort of
point number one point number two the
second law of thermodynamics is not a
law in the conventional sense
it's only as we see a statistical
likelihood in fact if you don't mind I'm
going to do one other example if I can
bring this up on the screen just to show
you what I mean it's not that entropy
can't go down is just that it's unlikely
to go down in fact in a simple system
let me not do so many coins let me do 10
coins and let me
imagine that I don't know but start with
let's start with five up so we're going
to start completely disordered five
heads five tails and let's say we flip I
don't know three on each time we're
jiggling around or let's not do three
let's do let's do I don't know no no no
three maybe that's okay
whatever I'm not sure how many times you
guys do it many times let's do it
I don't know 10,000 times and how many
toss I better do a lot we're gonna be it
forever the computer's gonna take
forever so let me do sort of I don't
know 100 tosses as we plot this let me
bring over here so I can bring that over
quickly that graph okay there it is oh
and look at that you see we started
right here in the middle at the 50-50
but notice over time we are going we're
fluctuating to highly ordered states
where we have all heads and all tails
the reason is because we only got ten
coins but my point is here's an example
that accentuates the likelihood of that
rare fluctuation from disorder to order
the reverse of what we are used to and
that's kind of beautiful because we see
that the second law is just a
statistical tendency it is not a law I
mean Newton's second law is along it is
not a tendency Schrodinger's equation is
meant to be a law not a likelihood the
second law of thermodynamics is however
a tendency an overwhelming tendency but
a tendency nevertheless entropy can go
down it is just unlikely for that to
happen okay what is my third point my
third point is this have we answered the
question of the arrow of time you might
think we have because now we understand
why glasses shatter and we don't ever
see them unshod we now understand why
whatever a candle burns but we never see
it unburned we never see all the the
fumes
come back together in order to recreate
the candle in it reforms we never see
that because those would be entropically
decreasing processes which can happen as
it just hope does it just unlikely they
become ever more unlikely when the
number of particles involved is ever
larger that's why I only use 10 pennies
and the example where I wanted you to
see fluctuations to lower entropy but
have we fully enter the question not not
really because you still want to ask
yourself if the high entropy states are
the more likely ones why do we ever have
any order at all why do we have a
pristine wineglass where did its order
come from if if it's unlikely to have
ordered States and more likely that
disordered states why don't we just as
always disordered where did the order
come from and to try to answer that
question it's natural to think
temporarily you can say ok today the
universe has a certain amount of entropy
if the second law holds do you think
that yesterday you'd have less entropy
in the day before less entropy and if
you follow this all the way back then
you're led to the Big Bang and you're
led to imagine that the Big Bang was a
highly ordered low entropy state the
lowest entropy that the universe has
ever had and we don't have an argument
that establishes that the Big Bang was
highly ordered that it had low entropy
we posit it it's a hypothesis is usually
called the past hypothesis I believe
David Albert gave this hypothesis that
name it's not that everybody believes
that this is the right way to go but I'm
describing one chain of reasoning which
at least holds together
albeit under the assumptions that it
makes and the assumption is that for
whatever reasons the early universe had
extraordinarily low entropy
extraordinary high order which means and
I can just go back over here for a
second to give a better picture so I can
have a nice
have to show this with so if we do our
thousand 0:25 say let's do it one
thousand times and let's make this go
really fast cuz I don't have time to
wait and I'm the graph is happening here
every well you can sort of see it pretty
fast but the point is the beginning of
the universe highly ordered over time
the entropy has been increasing and
we're sort of here we're in a part of
the unfolding an interesting question is
does the universe have a maximum entropy
I don't need to go all the way up here
but we're over here say where the
universe still has some residual order
from the Big Bang so the idea is the
reason why there can be ordered
structures my wine glasses and candles
and flowers and planets and people and
stars the reason why there can be
ordered structures in the universe is
because the Big Bang was so
fantastically ordered that in route to
ever greater disorder and route on that
journey there is still residual order
from the Big Bang along the way so I
like to say you know when you drop a
wineglass in it smashes or an egg
splatters on the floor you are actually
witnessing something that's deeply
connected to the Big Bang itself because
the very existence of the wineglass the
very existence of the egg relies upon
the orderly BIGBANG for there to be any
order today which can be embodied in say
a wineglass or an egg or a planet or a
person or any of the structures that are
ordered in the world around us so this
is key to the arrow of time it's not
just that entropy increases over time
it's not just that order degrades into
disorder it's also that there's an
anchor you have to explain why there's
any order at all or else there wouldn't
be any opportunity for order to degrade
into disorder and to explain why there's
any order at all we're led right back to
the Big Bang and the
that the Big Bang was a highly ordered
low entropy state and with that
assumption the past hypothesis that the
beginning was highly ordered and with
the second law of thermodynamics and the
tendency overwhelming tendency of
entropy to increase over time we get a
natural orientation of time a natural
notion of what it means to head toward
the future so the laws of physics
agnostic about past and future as we
started out any trajectory that can
unfold toward the future the reverse
trajectory also solves the equations of
motion so the laws of physics agnostic
about what we call past and future but
with the past hypothesis low entropy
beginning and the second law of
thermodynamics we have an orientation to
time that then emerges is that the end
of the story no I mean we want to
understand
can we give an explanation for why the
Big Bang was highly ordered can we give
some deeper principle that explains how
that order came to be or do we need to
simply accept that we have say one
universe and that's how began period end
of story that's it or as some have
suggested maybe there's a pre maybe
there's another side to time maybe time
doesn't begin at the Big Bang and maybe
as some have suggested if you go through
the Big Bang and should be increases in
a symmetric way so maybe you start with
a very high entropy infinite pass it
comes down to our Big Bang and then from
there and heads again back toward very
high entropy that would be completely
symmetric that's a possibility to that
people talk about but in any event the
one that at least at the moment that I
find most convincing
past hypothesis second law of
thermodynamics entropy tending to
increase from the highly ordered
beginning and that is where the
asymmetry and our experience comes from
that's why we never see those things
that make us laugh in Reverse run films
those things that look up surd they're
not absurd based upon the laws of
physics
they're absurd based upon our assumption
about the orders of the Big Bang and our
understanding from entropy in the second
law of thermodynamics have this
overwhelming tendency to head from order
toward disorder okay that's all I wanted
to say today and maybe a natural next
step at some point soon will be to apply
these ideas of entropy relating to
information maybe something an
information theory with Shannon would be
good but also to relate them to the
physics of black holes where entropy and
these ideas really flower in an
unexpected and deep way anyway that's
for the future
but after today our of time entropy Big
Bang past hypothesis that's all I wanted
to say for today until next time this
has been your daily equation take care